somebody asked me backstage they said um  the couple older folks in here and do  you change your material for the age of  the people who are sitting in front of  you  and uh no uh  i'm gonna tell you why too my  grandmother knocked that notion out of  me  quick because the first time she saw me  i was super nervous i didn't want to  swear in front of her you know  so she catches me backstage and she goes  you look  nervous i said i am i'm really nervous  and she said why are you so nervous  i said well i don't want to swear in  front of you nana  and she said what word exactly do you  not want to say  and i said well i don't want to say [ __ ]  in front of you  and she said sweetheart i had to [ __ ]  for you to get here and i was like  to the show man i had given you a ride  [ __ ]  i don't need you on the side of the road  like my grandson needs to work  you know  [Music]  [Music]  foreign